hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
kevin samuels
and fit and fresh podcast video so it's
titled modern women are angry that the
world isn't fair
three-on-one real-time debate before i
start do not forget to like
comment and subscribe um i'm trying to
get to 15 000 subscribers
so you know if you like my content
subscribe or don't doesn't really matter
okay because you know
you're gonna watch the video anyway all
right
modern women are angry that the world
isn't fair this
sounds fun hey guys how are we doing
we're good kevin how are you
good the ladies are in the middle her
name is sable
amanda but close enough amanda uh the
one
the woman to her right your name is
adriana adriana and the woman to your
left
janina janina okay one of the things i
kept hearing my name is kevin samuels by
the way nice to meet you
one of the things i kept hearing is the
notion of fairness
fairness fairness why is that so
important to you
amanda i
hate to admit it but i do like i'm half
a man i'm just a pretty girl and
i don't think that i should have to
accept less in life because i was born
with different equipment i think that's
[ __ ]
well if you're half a man that you
should understand this full concept that
men don't care about fair
i don't have to care about fair either
no no no men don't care about fear or
else he wouldn't conquer other people
here of european descent looks like
you're from you looks like you're from
people are from the caucus mountains
european descent
huh i am very white yes that's fine and
some of them
and there's a lot and between
a lot of warring tribes germania the
franks
if we cared about fairness we would just
let everybody stay on their land
vikings wouldn't have raped and pillaged
england would have stayed on its island
scotland would have been all right
ireland would have been all right matter
of fact hong kong wouldn't have been
a british protectorate for how many
years oh until the last what
30 or 40.
i have a comment about fairness what
i've realized is you really
dealt the hand you're dealt you know i
was born perfectly like
able like two arms two legs
and some people don't even have like
full cognitive function or full physical
function
so it's just you can't really like
comparison's a thief of joy so if you're
constantly comparing like what do they
have is it fair is it fair is it fair
like
you will not be happy and it's hard not
to like i think it's part of human
nature a little bit
but yeah just my two sons don't care
about fear we conquer
it's winners and losers
right you're half a man i didn't know
that only men were
part of conquering well maybe name me
some great female warriors that have
dominated the planet
joan of arc right that's what i always
think of when i think of like
female warriors i went to catholic
school well i mean i
i'm i'm learning new education here
which is only men conquer
no i mean that's what you're telling me
right no well see what i'm not gonna do
i'm not gonna switch that i'm asking
about fairness
and i said about fairness why is
fairness so important you said because
you're half a man
because if you expect something of me i
should be allowed to expect the same of
you and if you can't offer me that you
don't deserve to be in my life but that
has nothing to do with fairness
has everything to do with fairness no
fairness means you get an opportunity
fairness doesn't mean you get an outcome
damn you get an interview not guaranteed
a job no you're not but i work
very very hard to ensure that i keep it
well if that's the case you should
that's the case if that's the case then
if that's the case you should be able to
secure the things you want so you should
have no problem
obviously not not when men are out here
believing like you don't have to be fair
well those two things can't exist in the
same place we haven't even been part of
human history it's just men and all we
care about is
well no no that's not true though like
you guys realize women didn't want the
right to vote
like the majority of women did not want
the right to vote
and it's not like women were miserable
throughout all of history
like people always look at history as if
they know what was best for people at
that time
like you're supposed to look that look
at history through the eyes of the
oppressor and
that's what irritates me she's just
assuming like she knows what
what was best for women in a past like
century
like don't you think the people at the
time knew what was best
i'm and i'm i'm in no way saying like we
shouldn't be able to get
get to do equal things but there was a
reason
why at that time period they had the
rights that they did
no you just said you work very hard
so you should get the outcomes see if
hard work was all that required then we
would almost be guaranteed
hard work gets you a ticket to the dance
it doesn't get guarantee you the top
spot
how many uh who lost the super bowl guys
the uh kansas city chiefs can you say
they worked hard this year
very hard number two
men don't worry about fairness we worry
about winning until the victor goes the
spoils
just like you know what how many times
you've gotten to a club into vip for
free
when some ugly chicks had to pay full
price is that my fault
no no no i've asked how many times does
it happen before you go down that path
yeah but that's what he's saying you say
it's not fair
like this is what i always talk about on
this channel i don't by any
means think i'm ugly a lot of people
think that i'm like putting myself down
i just never was in the position where i
could like rely
solely on my looks for like getting into
bars
getting free drinks all night you know
getting
different opportunities it happened
sometimes but
it wasn't i wasn't in a position
to like do that but i'm not mad you know
it is what it is i was single for a
really long time so i developed a lot of
hobbies
plenty of times in miami exactly but
that's not fair is it
well please don't forget i'm not from
here but that's not the point ma'am
that's not fair is it
i also don't care about those things but
oh so you only care about fairness when
it
when it doesn't benefit yeah i just
don't go to clubs that often
but that's not the point i asked you how
many times you've gone to a club you got
into free
with ugly chicks the less attractive
chicks had to pay and you know that's
happened
you didn't say i'm still excuse me sir
uh even though i'm attractive i demand
that you charge me full price
that's fair right okay so because
in the places and getting this career
that means that i should get
before we go that i'll answer your
question if you're at least after mine
is that fair
life isn't fair well if that's right you
accept it in the sexual marketplace too
it doesn't mean i have to accept other
people's [ __ ] well see the thing is
ma'am
see what you've proven like many
feminists to many women
you're okay with the double standards
that benefit you yeah but the ones you
don't like you just throw at the wind
you sign language shame insults guilt
and the need to be right
to deflect and dismiss guys who are
normally intimidated by this thing i'm
not
i'm just challenging your position where
they're not being fair when it benefits
you
you're over simplifying a very complex
situation no it's not really complex
there are no such thing as loyal out the
concept of a loyal
highly effective competitive alpha is a
female notion and have to
continue to compete with other pretty
girls because men are
too simple to to stick with one well how
about this
the kind of man you're talking about is
simple enough to make the light you live
in the air conditioning
all the stuff that you hold on excuse me
ma'am the simple men
built the world that you use i built my
own world so
no man you used the world we built no
man you you used the world men built
name you five great female inventors
i'll give you one madam curry
i just i can't believe you so you're
telling me that men
to be fair i don't think i could name
five male inventors
but he's probably right he's probably
researched that more than i have ma'am i
just asked you a question and you did no
you go
see you're answering questions with
questions we're talking about building
naming five great female inventors or
builders
madame curie five inventors or builders
that's a really great question
that really is yeah it was gonna well
also i don't remember the lady's name
but she there's
a bunch of buildings in miami
she's afraid go on and do it don't wanna
get on in there baby girl you got it
miami was established by a woman
congratulations
but the miami the the land was
established by but this come
this country was first landed by who
men are women men exactly i agree with
you
and see the thing is i've done this show
about survival and you can go back to
bear grylls island number two
man you can only be a feminist in the
first world country
there's a hierarchy of needs you are
correct we are we don't need you
college and we don't need you you need
us great
i don't need you either no we need you
know we don't need you for survival you
need us for survival
okay so what i'm trying to get you to
understand ma'am is you have a right to
your opinion
obviously i don't have a right to
anything well you know you have a right
to believe what you want but the thing
is you're not
you're not allowed to the outcome you're
allowed to have an opinion just like
commanders are allowed to have an
opinion
and you don't have to compete or deal in
a situation that you deem is unfair
but you can't complain about the rules
that are already set
you like the rules that benefit you
getting into the club for free
but you don't like the rules that
benefit men high value and have the
leverage thank you because i'm 30
[ __ ] one years old and i'm getting a
little fed up of these men
kind of attacking me i do not go to
clubs anymore
so please stop but i bet she did when
she
when she was that age
double standard [ __ ] i work in a
man's world and if anything i've had to
work
five times as hard in this world as a
man to get where i am
oh no what does she do for a living
because i worked in sales and i was the
only girl at my work and i
guarantee
that there wasn't a difference like it
it was who sold more
now since you want to tell me you've had
to you you're 31 years old and have to
work in a man's world that's a privilege
you if you don't
here's the man here's the thing man you
you keep you say the problems with men
the only one that's complaining about
the double standard
harshly is you yes it benefits you too
benefits okay well here's the thing
ma'am if you don't like
okay ma'am you're a competent woman
correct okay so i should quit my job and
now you should build
you should build you should build
amazonia
and make it and make it the female
utopia that benefits women
i probably should after a little well
then go ahead agree with you
and then you but then but see then you'd
have to actually build something
you'd have to put your mouth where you
have to put your brain where your mouth
is i don't understand what you're saying
again that you came at me with the same
line i've had to put over 31 years old
and deal with men's [ __ ] you're
living in a first world country
here in miami one of the most posh
places on the planet complaining about
double standards that you participated
corrected you that i don't go to pub so
you're done
ma'am i just gave an example you've been
to clubs i didn't say you continue to go
that's not the point now is it
but see that's another way of you trying
to get me online and correcting me
because i'm a dumb man i get the point
no you're i mean you're very rude and
very aggressive you know i'm very direct
and when you were doing this to the men
you had no problem showing your dick
i'm just like i'm just acknowledging
your balls you know you're a tough woman
why why should i why because i'm just
giving what you give i'm reflecting back
what you give to people but see the
thing is you're okay giving this to
people
i'm just challenging what you think
these were my opinions when i came in
here i'm the one that presented these
opinions
i just listened to you for two nights
say these things and i'm just talking to
you one-on-one
and you're not backing down i'm just i'm
just challenging what you say man
do a bunch of weak ass men tell me that
i'm not attractive and i'm not this and
i'm not that
because i am not going to back down and
listen to somebody
okay are you saying the men in the room
with you a bunch of week asked me if you
think that i should have to accept
leslie no ma'am i don't think you should
have to do anything you don't want to
you're
a free person but i'm trying to
understand who are the weak-ass men
you're referring to
amazonia because who are the weak-ass
man you're referring to
she looks like such an idiot before the
week asked me and you're referring to
what did i just say do i need to hear
you because you because
you guys are talking over me so could
you repeat it a bunch of weak-ass men
doing what
yes when somebody sits here and tells me
i need to accept an unfair situation
that if we applied it to anything else
in life other than men and women
wouldn't be accepted
by everybody in this room but you're
gonna tell me that i'm gonna tell you
that's [ __ ]
what is the unfair situation and that's
not fair
okay can i give a response
there's a million issues in our culture
and society today
that people are fighting for fairness
but yet i'm sitting here sitting saying
hey i'm allowed to expect it too
and i'm going to be attacked and told
okay okay can i respond now
different okay no let me tell you
something first of all
men don't worry about fair the sexual
marketplace is not fair
all is fair in love and war it's not
fair
there are guys that out there that you
wouldn't give the time of day who could
have a heart of gold because they don't
hit your
mark oh no ma'am i let you speak that's
true
that's very true a lot of
a lot of girls overlook guys that would
make really good husbands because they
don't
like tall in shape whatever it is don't
know that
no i know that you don't give every man
a chance is what i do know
you don't well actually you don't know
that at all okay you give okay are you
saying that you are the one female on
the planet
that will give every man who wanted you
a shot
no i am not okay then i can assume that
that was correct let's move on
let's not get lost in okay that's a
deflection let's not get lost in that
i don't know you're talking about
unfairness unfairness where in the world
is it fair like you needed to be is it
fair for you here in america
no ma'am i ask you where in the world is
it fair like i'm not complaining about
it
i'm not i'm not i deal with it i deal
with the unfairness and overcome it
because i'm a man and i can deal with it
and i'm asking you where is this place
where is where is this ideal place
where's the ideal model exactly
three women here sitting like here never
wanting to go on a date again
well no how about not wanting to go on a
date
what's happening in this world more than
anything else is mankind has learned how
to get along with each other since
recorded history
but along around the 60s when the
national organization for women the era
phyllis not phyllis schlapley she was on
our side when all this stuff came in
feminism second
wave feminism i'm a feminist i believe
in feminism feminism is about choice
oh you really use me ma'am feminism in
its true form is about choice
yeah we don't have a choice right now
with whatever you have a choice what she
just actually smiles
right now it got too hot she left
what do women not of a choice
i've had every choice that a guy has had
am i trying to think of something that i
haven't had a choice in
see it's about choice if a woman wanted
to be a housewife she could do it if she
wanted to be a business
person she could do it see the choice
was about all black people wanted was
a choice freedom to be have an equal
shot not equal outcomes
men accept these things you don't hear
me in complaining about fair
if donovan and i were playing a game of
football or video game
if he was kicking my [ __ ] ass i would
be a punk to sit up and say it's not
fair my controller's not working the
game is rigged
that's not fair you're better do you
know i would have to just take my ass
whooping take my elves and get better
that's what men do
that you guys choose to be this way and
we like we don't want to choose to be
that way we want to be different we want
we don't want somebody that's going to
achieve we don't want anybody
like we want someone that's that's going
to be faithful why do we have to settle
for these types of things that you're
saying
well first of all you don't have to
settle for anything you don't have to do
anything you don't want to
but what also does not have to happen is
men don't have to be counted to their
nature
to make you happy and that's okay
so what's the issue the issue is that
men are not the ones complaining about
the state of relationships and dating as
much as women are
women wanted freedom of choice women
wanted to be able to
have sex with who they wanted to marry
who they want to love who they want to
work where they want to not work where
they want to go every place that men
could go
you are the most free most liberated
group of women that ever existed on the
human history
and yet you're the most unhappy one in
four out of you on some sort of psych
men's
women one in four women are on psych
meds
and our fault the marital rate is
dropping with modern women
what else do you want men to do we've
civilized the world in general we don't
even have wars you can do whatever you
want to
and you're still not happy with the
world the men built telling us
that we're not good enough because we
don't move like women we're not going to
i just feel like you guys don't put in
effort
i feel like the most most are you
serious
i do feel like you're serious that i
don't put an effort
i mean the way that you're talking it
doesn't seem like it like no but she's
right in this in a sense because just
what you guys are saying
most guys today that's 80 percent of
guys that you
guys let's let's not get lost in this
because when they can get into vip by
just
being the hottest woman in the club
that's okay
why is that your only argument yeah this
is the one that everybody understands
because it's the one that everyone
understands and i could use more
trust me i'm a smart guy i can give you
more
but the point of the matter is it's the
one we understand and the double
standard benefits you you're okay with
what effort are women putting in today
women still want men to move in the
traditional way
but yet you're not traditional women
i agree with this like
i don't think that give it like that
women
sleeping around um like
saying i don't need a man men are trash
none of the worst like do these girls
seem happy to you
do they seem like they're happy with
where they're at in life are they
married
like it doesn't lead to happiness
button uh i'm confused i'm asking
men to act in a traditional way you want
men to be traditional i mean most women
okay i run a show that has anywhere from
15 to 20 000 people watching every night
women from women around the world
consistently say they want a man that's
earning in the high five low six figures
they want to have two to three
kids and be married most women want the
top ten percent of men
you can go watch my channel and see this
beared out black white asian hispanic
middle eastern and other across the
board
all these women are given an option do
you want to have to work to pay
significant bills after you're pregnant
the answer comes back overwhelmingly no
meaning they want to be traditional stay
at home housewives they were raised that
way
they weren't cultured that way they're
not even equipped to be that way but yet
they and if you ask them could you date
an average guy earning fifty thousand
dollars even women coming straight out
of college turn their nose up
men accept this excuse me
can i finish my exam today you said he's
making 80 000
and that wasn't enough okay so men
accept this
meaning i think i'm like
i'm like one of the only girl i think
it's just because i've been watching
this and all these girls are like the
same
but i really would not mind like
being like i don't think i'd like being
a housewife
the fact that college men accept the
fact that they're in school right now
with women
their own age that 80 years ago they
could have married
and had a family early on now they're
looking at these same women and these
same women would not even look
at these guys unless they're making six
figures men have accepted the unfairness
in the marketplace it's not fair for men
18 to 30 men used to could get married
now you can't even really consider
getting married till you're 35
plus because you have to have resources
that's the new market
why why i don't get that
it is but let me finish let me say this
now let's turn it over
men have accepted that and adjusted the
difference is the women are not bringing
any
women in mass are bringing this ask them
what you want you get one piece
ask you what you bring to the table you
can't write on the back of a stamp you
get access to my body which is not
virgin which is not even low miles which
you've given to somebody before and in
some cases you've even shared your wound
you're not even really feminine like
women used to be you don't even have the
domestic skills the home skills
so is it a i would so i would submit
today that modern women are asking for
an
unfair deal for modern men so we should
go back to 1950 and make it more fair
well uh i tell you what what's happening
is well if you want to do that that's
fine but you should be okay with paying
50
of the bills like
i have a lot of friends that are in
relationships and they pay 50 50
or like 60 40 whatever
like if you don't want to stay home
clean and take care of the kids which is
totally fine like do it i'm always about
like do what makes you happy
but just my two seconds
have accepted this and there's deciding
to i am neither not going to play this
game because i cannot
earn what these guys around you are
earning and they're just opting to walk
away
and the men who are earning that have an
overwhelming
amount of options they have a plethora
of
men in the top ten percent top five
percent i'm 51 years old and i can pick
whatever i want
because women all want the same kind of
man and if you have options just like
you
you're not going to do what settle
men didn't make it the men didn't make
the marketplace this way ladies you
fought for it to be this way
this is freedom freedom comes with
responsibility
clearly not not for men no no see when
men were paying the bills
when we had the old system men were
expected to fight the wars dig the
ditches build the buildings pay all the
bills
and when when a divorce or something
happened men had to pay
now women fall for equality so you get
upset when you deal with 50 50 mindset
men
no i mean i'd rather be an independent
rich woman and be singled and to be
stuck with a man who doesn't give away
and i would
rather pay more than half of the bill
absolutely exactly okay first off you
said you'd rather be in it and if that's
what you choose to be great you can do
that that's
choice and you can do that exactly
but the thing is but the funny thing is
you would think that
and especially in my community strong
independence such and so forth
the amount of women who are high earners
independent and miserable
is laughing is amazing halle berry
once the most beautiful woman on the
face of the planet three times in a row
is complaining about child support
she's rich she's beautiful she's
miserable
how about this that we used to be a time
where men and women actually did not war
with one another we didn't have these
contentious things
we accepted the men were men women were
women we acknowledge each other's
differences we respected those things
and let the world work
in the last 70 years we've decided let's
rejigger everything it's not working
and you could rape your wife and she
didn't have any rights and you could
beat her
now what's going on guys is this is this
the sign language that goes on again
this is when they go to the
the horror stories in the black
community we call this the color
purpling of black america
yes these things could happen sure but
they did not happen in mass you did not
go
to suburbia and see women's eyes hanging
out their socket
and that's the thing people act like
just because those things like did
happen at a time that
it happened widespread throughout
society when in 2021
people are people people did not change
in the like like human nature doesn't
change across the board
like i'm sure it was similar rates as it
is today
i find a guess someone fact check me in
the comments
because i don't know the answer to that
just you know common sense
i highly disagree with you i mean raping
your wife was such a huge deal i didn't
even get
eyes hanging out of your socket you
talking about i'm not going to use that
word because i'm on somebody's platform
can we not use that word though because
we're not using that can we not use that
word
it's youtube sensitive i'm i'm sorry
what word
the r word par spelled backwards
it's it it dings the platform okay i'm
not rejecting the concept
yes ma'am it happened right man but what
you're trying to think that
was better for me okay well then if the
world is better for you
then accept the things that come along
with a better world i just think that
everything you guys are presenting are
opinions and they're not
fat well actually there are more facts
than you want to deal with because i
deal with
in fact if there are things that you
guys want to say are facts okay
ma'am statistics show me this we go okay
ma'am
my show all i deal with facts and
statistics women
that are are happy in their environment
knowing they're being cheated on
knowing these things are happening to
them and you find them for me how many
women we have
me hold on let me ask the question again
ask the question again you go find these
women that are being happy being cheated
on they're
they're happy and leave me oh don't hold
on
i will excuse me i can go i'll let you
know i can go out to
where i lived you live in dallas in
highland park i knew at least six of
them
six of them because excuse me ma'am and
that i've been here
excuse me if you let me explain to you i
will you're not letting me finish my
thought and then you
ask the question that you ask the
question go find these women and i'm
going to tell you where i found them
over i said in successful marriages okay
in successful marriages ten years later
and they're still married
still married still married there was a
soccer that
the soccer one okay okay do you want to
hear or not
well i mean i just don't i would you see
i could give you the example and you
still won't accept it
because there are some women who accept
the fact that you know what if i want to
have a man that's making
400 500 000 a year that kind of living
he's not going to be able to go to the
pta meetings he's going to have to work
his butt off
and maybe travel a lot and guess what
they have an arrangement
but guess what as long as you don't
bring in in home any outside babies
no diseases that don't embarrass me in
public we're good guess what she can
also do what she wants to do as well
and they have an understanding because
get when the the marital rate in this
country the divorce rate in this country
is over 51
but when you cross a net income of 250
000
it drops to 20 because people with more
money got more reasons to stay together
and they find a way to do it all the
time
i respect your but at what cost the cost
of your soul
like money doesn't buy happiness
and because at least it's fair at least
people get to have a part of a deal
instead of just men get to key and women
are going to sit at home and deal with
it
what i just gave you was an it was a
fact that anybody can look at
well but again i'm more okay with what
you're saying you're telling me it's
going both ways not just one
well i'm telling you it always is going
both ways but wait the way you guys are
set up is it's always women of the
victims
and that's that feminism crap i don't
think women no
that's true women cheated i would
guarantee that women
cheat at similar rates as much and i
think women can pick and choose
i think there are plenty of women like
melania trump to choose to be married to
a guy like donald trump
and knew exactly what she was getting
was perfectly fine with being where she
is
that's a choice i don't think i've ever
sat here and claimed to be a victim but
she is the worst
i mean she's probably the best example
because i'm not a i'm not a
front fan but like she's the worst
example to bring into that because it's
like
she's not she had the freedom to choose
and she chose and she did oh you're
going to negate her choice
absolutely she wasn't an american she
made her choices basically
oh listen to that see this is what
this is what it is this is a selective
feminism it's feminism only when it goes
with what i think thank you for proving
my point
i'd like to make a and that's
women are free to pick what they want i
just personally couldn't
do that actually so if we brought up
that plenty of colombian women run game
on white guys in miami for citizenship
we would act like they're victims
no i wouldn't guys i wouldn't melania
trump does the same thing
citizenship she gets some cash she gets
she gets what
you are perceiving as a good deal so let
me explain let me let me say something
guys
let me explain something to you ladies
what men and women have always done
is not worried about the western notion
ideal of marriage
what men and women have traditionally
done to sat down and negotiated and
hammered out a deal
and that's what they do you hammer out a
deal melania trump
got a deal she is not a prisoner she
could have chosen to leave this is a
free country if donald trump wanted her
to stay and she wanted to leave she
could have
she chose to be there yeah but we're not
all like melania trump
that is not a valid argument no but i
don't think
it's not because we're not that's not a
valid argument i'm saying the fact that
there are women who make choices that
you don't understand but they're
free to make them and happy in those
situations but again
talking about choices that are going
both ways when what i have been getting
annoyed with
is there is no sense of fairness i think
what she's trying to say is that she
feels like men have the right to cheat
and women don't
um
i like don't even know what to say to
that um
i don't know i just think like if you
want to be in a relationship
where there's cheating and they both
know that that's fine that's your choice
if you're happy being cheated on that's
fine
but at what cost like are those values
values you want to instill in your
children
is that like the type of
values you you want to spread
people can do what they want you know
that's what it is there is no
dating man that's what you don't seem to
get there's no fairness in this
all's fair and loving war it's not fair
it's survivable
i'm glad i know now i just got a lot of
empowerment
now that i heard everybody's opinion
here it's like i don't even want to date
like i'm
oh i do i'm just gonna i'm gonna be even
more excited
but understand something and you can do
that but here's the thing
and that's defined and that's fine but
but here's the thing
and the thing and while you're running
game the game will be playing as well
that's fine and men are okay with that
see men are okay with the
okay with that though ma'am you ladies
set up the rules we are playing
we are playing the game that modern
women have set up
so kevin and i don't know if you heard
it but again one of the things that's
bothered me is that again it's
oh well men can do this but women can't
success
again the cheating thing well if you're
the one percent of men then you get to
do this and it's because
women show you know love differently and
blah blah blah
well i'll put it to you this way if
you're if you're with a one percent man
and you're cheating
uh you better not get if
you need to know you're a man neither
are neither i mean
i will say this i know men in the one
percent whose wives have
what do you think the porn where she's
sleeping with the pool boy the postman
came from women cheated the postman
rings twice was a very famous movie in
the 70s
ladies there are some men who understand
their wife's teeth they're just rules to
it
but again i like that you're telling me
we're setting a plan
up front because that's not what's been
being said that's always what it comes
down to
he loves you he ain't gonna let you know
he's there is something that comes down
that when you if you
there is some man on the planet that you
can actually make a deal with that you
could accept
now the point is can you find them
before time runs out but that's how it
always comes down to
there are blanket generalizations that
are broadly true for most people
but we're human beings everyone has a
choice some guys cannot tolerate any
cheating
well then if you need to get your itch
scratched and you know what you got on
the line you gotta risk
ready to risk reward because if you want
to risk it aim lower i guess you know
lower your uh expectations because if
you're look
you're dating you know above the one
percent then you might get somebody
that's not going to [ __ ] cheat right
maybe well hold on and see the notion of
this whole aim lower
this is why when women who say this i
don't think you realize that people
when you don't think a lot of times you
ladies understand when you say aim lower
you're in that lower too
where's the freaking point i don't aim
lower i'm not going down lower i'm just
gonna
well you have to understand
what these women are making it seem like
money is the only thing a guy has to
offer
good husband good father like
it's not just about money
realities women control access to sex
and determine whether or not a life is
brought into the world
men control access to relationships in
marriage
so you can aim whatever you want to but
unfortunately
men across the board low value to high
control access to relationship that's
what we control
so this is what i was saying earlier
ladies across the board you can have
your standards your point of view
but when it comes right down to it the
way
you guys were talking is if you had
leverage over the kind of men that was
in the discussion you
don't those men have leverage over the
women you're not you're not competing
you're competing with the women around
him
they're everything that you ladies are
saying i won't tolerate this such and so
forth
there are plenty other women be like
[ __ ] okay fine what else is that it no
problem
saying we're not one percent like they
i'm saying that there are more women
wanting
them than there are men there
there's one percent that means 99 aren't
and almost 100 of women want the same
one percent of men the petrol principal
oh yeah
are more women trying to okay you've all
been into a club at some point in your
life
there's there's a regular club and
there's vip
the guys who are in vip are looked at
differently
than the guys who are standing online
that's not fair kevin
well what the guys in vip had to make
see the thing is one thing
that most women don't seem to realize
and and it's very simple
women are born with inherent value
so they really can't understand the
concept that we men have to deal with
we have to make ourselves value so when
men hear that we have to make ourselves
valuable
we accept the world as it is and we
don't sit back and say well it's not
fair
we just deal with the world as it is
here's the principle women can never
objectively understand the male journey
and struggle so don't try to explain
in general they see everything through
rose-colored glasses being born with
inherent value
you earn all of your value as a man and
it's your greatest opportunity that you
could hope for
not always like height you didn't earn
height
women are born with value i mean they're
not
you all had your uh struggle the women
are still struggling right
now because they're way harder to be a
woman than a man that's a value man i
said value
yourself no you went you do it to how
hard it is i said value
nobody's feeling sorry for themselves i
said value
are you i'm so you're entitled to
something better because your struggle's
been harder
no one that nobody see me don't think
we're entitled to anything that's why we
said i don't even
know what i said was don't what i said
was men should not try to explain
if you weren't entitled you wouldn't sit
here and talk i don't deserve the same
oh no
yeah you can knock the sign language off
it doesn't work on me what i was saying
is i don't try
men should not try to objectively
articulate your struggle and journey to
be a man
because women are born with inherent
value see kevin she stopped listening
it's it's i know i know and i'm about to
run but i'm gonna say this for the
audience thank you for
having me on guys and these are oh my
goodness
look
that i'm like so tired of listening to
people argue
let me know in the comments like some
not
as argumentative videos maybe i could
watch like
i hear i hear what kevin samuels is
saying when it comes to like
men and women have like the option to
cheat but
for me it just goes back to like what
costs at the cost of your soul
i don't know um let me know in the
comments
what i should react to next don't forget
to like comment
and subscribe i'll talk to you guys next
time